نعم تروين لا احب العربيه هذا ليس كلامي
هذا مقالي الاخير مره فعاليات اسبوع اللغه
العربيه هل تعتبرين ان لغتنا العربيه في
خطر اليوم ام ان لغه القران الكريم لا
يمكن لها ان تموت سؤال جدا حلو انا تكلمت
في هذا العمود عندي عمود همم اسبوعي
بجريده الامارات اليوم نلتقي همم العربي
زيه العربيه
اللغه التي نتكلم بها للاسف نكتب بها يعني
هذه الجيل الان يكتب الحروف همم يعني
الحروف الانجليزيه
ويكتبها بطريقه عربيه يعني يلفظها
بالطريقه العربيه هو همم يعني يلحنها كان
همم اللغه العربيه احنا ما راح نقول ان هي
في خطر هي سؤال جاءك حقيقه يعني انا ما
اريد اتفلسف على المشاهدين صباحا هل هو
قلق اللغه ام قلق اصحاب اللغه يعني لانه
اصحاب احنا نحمل لغه عندها ارث وعندها
ثقافه وعندها ولغه النص المقدسه عندنا
القران الكريم لكن حقيقه خلينا نكون
شفافين وواضحين اللغه في خطر يعني يوما ما
المفكر والمنظر للحداث العربيه هذه اللغه
ستنقرض وقاموا عليه يعني اقامه القيامه
يعني ادونيس الا ان هو يرى بعين المفكر
هذه اللغه احنا ما نستخدمها انا كثير من
الاحيان يعني اكون في اماكن عامه في مطعم
او مقهى اشوف يعني بنات من الجيل الجديد
وعرب زين قاعدين يتكلمون طول الوقت
بالانجليزيه ومره يصادف ظهور اقتربت من
وحده طيب ليش تتكلمين بالانجليزي ليش طول
الوقت يعني
قالت لي احنا بنتكلم لان احنا نشانا
ودرسنا وكده طيب قلت لها طيب هذه اللغه
اذا انتم مارستوها راح تنقرض راح تنتهي
يعني فعلا قالت لي جمله كثير لفتت نظري
قالت لا ما دكتوره لان هذه لغه القران
الكريم طيب سؤالي القران الكريم في البيت
يعلوه الغبار لا يمس ولا يقرا همم كيف
ممكن
هذا النص يفعل هذا الذكر لحافظون انا
نزلنا الذكر وانا له الحافظون طيب كيف
احنا نحفظ القران هل يكفي ان اتشدق واقول
ان هذا لغه القران الكريم وان لا اقرا
القران وانا لا اجود القران وانا لا ارتل
وانا لا امارس هذه اللغه يعني كيف ممكن
يضمن عنصر الحيويه والوجود لهذه اللغه لان
هذه اللغه تمارس هذه اللغه كان اجتماعي
اللغه كان اجتماعيه يعني يحيى وينمو على
السنه المتحدثين اذا لم نتكلم ولا نمارس
اللغه ستموت هذه اللغه يعني انا لما قلت
انا لا احب العربيه لان اللغه هذه لها
كاركتير يعني انا لما كنت ادرس لما ادخل
على الطلبه بالج فقالوا يجوني يسلمون عليه
همم هم يعتقدون ان انا ادرس ادب انجليزي
لاني لابسين لان حتى تصورنا في صور نمطيه
انه مدرسه العربي في كاركتير كان هذه
اللغه مبرقعه اولها في شيء في هاله لهذه
اللغه فيها الثقل وفيها كذا ليست قريبه من
الناس انا اريد يعني همي انه صادق اللغه
ان تكون
المطر مثل فنجان القهوه